so hey guys hey
is this your first time in Brazil first
time yes not my first time I've been
before I came about five years ago I
entered Sao Paulo actually so I know
what the fans here are like and that's
why I was so excited to come back and
meet them again so the convenient in a
good way in the better awesome
uh and you'd have a chance to learn any
words or
Allah oh
pesos
that's actually pretty good it's pretty
good very similar to the Brazilian
pronunciation I'm Brazilian so uh so we
have some really good uh we just had the
opportunity to see the first teaser for
three body problem and I have to tell
you guys your looks uh exciting uh it
has its visually stunning uh it looks
ambitious yes uh and I want to know for
you guys uh are you well what are you
guys most excited for people to see of
course without getting into any spoilers
I think in a funny kind of way we're
excited to see it as much as everybody
else is because because we shot a lot of
it so long ago and it's a lot of it's on
green screen so you can't really see
what's going on when we saw the trail it
was the first time we'd seen a lot of
those visual effects ourselves so we
didn't really get a sense of what it was
like when we were filming it so we can't
wait for people to see all of that the
finished product but likewise we're just
as excited as we hope they are to see uh
what about you guys gonna want to talk
about there's so many cool things to
look forward to
um
I think there were just so many twists
and turns so I can't wait for everyone
to go oh okay this is the show oh no oh
this is the show oh this is also the
show there's just so many layers to it
so it's like peeling an onion you know
hopefully will make everyone cry as well
okay okay that's exciting uh another
thing that uh we don't know much or
maybe at all about your characters
because everything is kept on the wraps
yeah so what I like for each of you to
tell us a little bit if you can uh what
what do you like most about your
character when you approach this and all
these General stuff without getting into
any spoilers of course yes well the
writing
um is so incredible and the dialogue is
so rich and I like just how full and
human my character felt and how fleshed
out
um and and profound uh his Arc is and uh
yeah I was just excited aside from it
being like a truly spectacular
um level production uh just also the
very human storyline was a delicious
thing as an actor to to get to yeah I
think I have to agree and it's something
about
seeing characters specifically for me
but also for all of the characters who
showed that they're flawed in their own
ways I think it's it's it can get boring
if you're watching programs or you have
like these cutouts of different
archetypes of characters and I like to
see people who are people and these are
people that audiences when they watch
the show they can relate to the people
that they're seeing on the screen and
relate to the things that they're going
through so that's what I really enjoyed
to piggyback off of Alex uh about the
dialogue and about how these different
uh characters were interacting with each
other throughout the series yeah yeah I
mean just like the complexity of all
these characters and just seeing them
all sort of interweave in all all in
their different Journeys I mean I think
uh
I don't know it's uh he's incredibly
committed you know and uh I sort of like
gumsia of the piece where uh nothing
else matters but
everything to them guys are good
there you go okay guys we're about to
jump to what's something about your
character it was an interesting one for
me actually because before I'd even read
this this first script I got a message
from David and Dan who I worked with on
Game of Thrones for all those years
telling me uh that this character was
the was the character most like the real
me that I'm ever gonna play
and so then then it was a case of
waiting for the script to find out what
they what kind of guy they think is
John's a multi-millionaire exactly yeah
and then and so we I hope people are
gonna have to wait and find out whether
I was flattered by that or whether I was
Gravely insulted
that lives here Jess
uh
see I
see I love how and
bitter is she is very uh
in a way I'm similar but I'm much more
kind of oh let's see what happens
whereas she's very focused on her goals
um to the point where you know she loses
side of other things sometimes and
that's kind of one of her flaws and I
love that what makes her great in her
field is also what makes her um not so
great in life I love that kind of
Duality
um and yeah just your curiosity about
the world because I feel like everybody
could remember to be more curious about
what's happening around them okay all
right that's great uh so
we're talking in sci-fi right uh and
ambitious projects and I want to know
about you guys are you big on sci-fi are
you huge sci-fi fans favorite Sci-Fi
movies they want to talk a little bit
about that I really enjoyed arrival oh
really
that's one that I've I've rewatched a
few times and I've uh I've gotten more
interested in Sapphire as as of late but
I really enjoyed the Sci-Fi uh material
that isn't just sci-fi and I think
that's another Testament to why
everybody wanted to come on board to do
this project as well is because there
are so many themes that are discussed in
this science fiction uh series that is
it's it's really exciting and compelling
and I think again the audiences will
really relate to all of the themes
discussed and fans who may not be
traditionally sci-fi fans uh would find
themselves watching the show uh not
particularly a Sci-Fi fan but um I mean
I like I liked arrival I like uh yeah if
it's good then it's good
um yeah if it's good storytelling
um I think what's exciting about this
this project is that it's sci-fi it's a
thriller it's action it's drama it's uh
it is incredible I think you said
ambitious earlier I think what they have
tried to do with this uh with these
books these unbelievable books is super
ambitious and super exciting
um so yeah it's thrilling to be part of
it for that reason and and the Sci-Fi
element as well since I mentioned the
books
um did you guys uh did you have heard
before about the the novels that's
important inspired the books or this is
your first contacts with the three
vertebra I'd heard of it but I hadn't
read them yeah same I I heard of it and
and I knew that the the reputation that
these books had for being
sort of adult focused very very dense
sci-fi but but rooted in a sort of
scientific reality as well almost but I
hadn't read them so so but I I think I
think what David and Dan have always
been very and Alex are very good at is
taking the book which is quite dense and
quite scientific and making them uh
approachable and making them feel
familiar and making them making them
human so if you're fans of the books
you'll love the show but but the show's
a sort of slightly different thing yeah
and and sort of like much more palatable
as well isn't there that's uh yeah and
it's um
I I really uh love what they've done
with the adaptation of it yeah we'll be
all right guys uh so I think I have a
quick question because I'm a very short
time uh uh what can you tell me can if
you can uh about welcome to Derry can
you say something or
oh well twist
um
it's called me off guard
I mean it's it's being made by the same
creators of of the films and everybody's
really excited and working on it and it
was working hard was we just started
filming so
there's very little that I can tell you
because we're still in a thick of it but
it's it's an exciting project for sure
uh Benny uh I want you to ask you do you
know when we'll see sorcerer Supreme
again
um well I sing every summer look in the
mirror but
um
yeah yeah I do cleaning the mirrors but
I don't know you know there's a special
phone in the corner that the Rings every
now and then yeah so so far the storm
hasn't
yeah no no yeah no yeah yeah so you're
waiting for this phone we'll see
okay right guys okay